shadow Allah Allah oh what a shadow oh
that's what my gloves protect mrs.
Bennet's thoughts of Muslim Allah awake
bed I said I'm like ingredients a piece
welcome to the DS Show
I am Eddie your host and while the whole
coronavirus pandemic is going on we have
people accepting his Deen because
they're thinking they're pondering what
is the purpose of life and one of those
people that got to reflecting got to
thinking accepted his Deen took his
Shahada during this pandemic is my next
guest and he's here to share his story
we'll have up here on the D show don't
go anywhere
[Music]
Germany or Austria in Austria yes you in
Austria so it's good to have you on it's
good to have you on the Dean show so I I
heard I heard you say that the
coronavirus gave me necessary freedom to
find my faith again
can you explain this yes that's true
so inshallah God Allah SWA metallic give
me the faith back what I lost this time
I find pick I have a lot of stress
everyone has a lot of stress and now
everyone comes slow down and begin to
you know what what's life yeah what my
purpose of life thinking purpose of life
yes yes about religion a lot of people
think about that uh-huh and many many
years ago pray five times ago every day
Islamic religion Muslims don't convert
it oh so you you are so the coronavirus
now that everything calmed down now
everybody's thinking like death reality
now you're thinking more about Islam
purpose of life yes
so of 2020 I was in jail you know and
this time I prayed I found to the Islam
religion uh-huh but I converted yeah I
don't say that this time and when I come
out I lost religion a lot a lot of
troubles
yeah normal life for normal people's huh
and now for a lot of weeks I've begin to
break again and I feel I feel ready for
for say to eat each other
so your so Islam was on your mind for a
long time for many years yes so when I
played when I played the music from
YouTube Holland even bolete yes yes I
have I have this song many time of my
handi but when I play in the car I
played only when I am alone now I now I
can play everywhere uh-huh masha'Allah
so this is uh this is something amazing
now you you are because there's a lot of
people because you're a professional
fighter who they have a lot of courage
to get in the cage but now when it comes
to find the truth and to be on the truth
you know they worried about what people
gonna say their image yes yes what can I
say about that I'm at home and like you
and all other one okay I'm a
professional father but this is not
important for me so now in my mind I'm
strong you know become yesterday Big
Sean's for a big fight versus a really
big man in Europe and I think I feel I
feel like ready to fight everywhere and
everyone my mind is so strong and this
is all about the religion it's only
about for Islam you said something about
at one point that you couldn't do
nothing because you are influence
politically yeah is that rid of time
where's the time now yeah
were you also where you were you when
you say you were influenced put it put
it politically because a lot of people
when they're in politics these
politicians they will use and bash Islam
or Muslims are terrorists making people
scared of Islam so when this was this
influencing you also that this was
having an impact on your decision that
you were you got caught up in all of the
misinformation that was out there about
Muslims and Islam I brought them the big
problem it's not only in Europe I think
it's all around the world the media or
the televisions and politics that make
dares refugees here's rape there is rape
it's only from refugees and but nobody
sees behind it what's really happened
with these humans it's it's amazing and
it's crazy what's happened there all
around the world and the politics makes
that for for hate to Islam yeah but it's
that's so so tell me you talk about how
Islam gave you the necessary strength
and for people that don't know Islam
simply means to submit yourself your
will to God's will to the Creator Allah
this and this is how you get peace in
life so tell me you talk about Islam
gave you the strength to get through
much of the hard times
mm-hmm yeah now I have no hard time you
know now I have a really really good
time and this is for me a lot of
people's find to her religion when it's
bad life but find to the religion when
you have good times and this is why I'm
saying now my life is good
I find to the religion and I find to
Islam I find to Allah and this is this
makes me really really happen mm-hmm you
know it makes me strong again
masha'Allah tell us about your friend is
his name Barack you like yes it's my
brother
yes so he he actually tell us about your
relationship with him he's how long have
you known him I know he made last year
yeah
I fight to process him oh you guys you
guys fought together yeah yeah yeah we
fight to miss temple uh-huh he win in
the first round before the five minutes
over he win is he's a really really
strong fighter not only his body strong
is his soul is wrong his faith is strong
and this was impressed for me you said
that he gave you Brock he gave you a cup
a gift what was the gift he gave me the
holy quran and for pray Tepe you know
what I mean yes yes the prayer rug yes
yes yes this yeah oh so he he was
sharing he was sharing what he loved the
most Islam with you yes yeah we are
after the fight with him we are always
in contact so we we like us you know we
love us and we'll make all these jokes
about our fight yes you know the game
when what is this a cut when you cut the
paper yes cut yes
scissor scissors yeah this one then in
stone and paper you know this game yeah
paper Rock scissor poom yeah the photos
in the internet when eyes see to him and
I punch him and we have all blood in the
face he is bloody face our face and I
say right sometimes I lost the game cut
paper in stone this is only for men
we have a we have of affiliate one of
our schools there in Istanbul jiu-jitsu
team resumix jiu-jitsu there so maybe we
when I go next time we can we can meet
there when I I did a seminar in Turkey
not last last year very nice well yes
inshallah we I heard you're also looking
forward now to it's amazing because you
just accepted Islam and we heard you
take this yeah that's what my gloves
became mrs. Bennet's thoughts of Muslim
Allah awake better a shadow la ilahe
illallah wa ashhadu anna muhammadan
abduhu wa rasuluh this is something that
it's just so natural that you testified
that there's nothing worthy of worship
except the creator of the heavens and
earth if you are living during the time
of Jesus you would say Issa Rasool Allah
during the time of Moses Moosa Rasool
Allah but you said now because human
beings are living during the time of the
last and final messenger prophet
Muhammad so you say Muhammad Rasul Allah
and now you have the five pillars of
faith you have prayer five times a day
and what now we're in you're excited
about Ramadan you're excited to start
fasting tell us about this yeah yeah
Ramadan first before I heard it always I
think it's very very hard for the pupils
but the Ramadan gives me so much love
every day I have people's here to make
if that or I am with people's to make
gift I read the Quran and I have no
troubles no when I make weight cut I eat
and drink 24 hours nothing so this now
it's not for mass this is now for I
wanted
and makes me makes me makes me happen
makes me really happen huh that's a
strong that's amazing because a lot of
people they'll sacrifice for a title for
money
they'll fast like they'd have to cut
wait they're torturing themselves right
but yeah yeah but now you you are you
are you're fasting you know for your
creator you know to get the spiritual
benefits and also you get health
benefits amazing yeah yeah what's
amazing is I say the Shahada and the
holy world shares my video and that
don't understand yeah that you what you
got welcomed into a huge family of
almost 2 billion they want to they want
to meet their brothers so they given you
a lot of love how does that experience
the love they're about but a lot of
people makes videos when they say when
they say the Shahada you know yeah and
they're not so famous laughs and I don't
want famous I don't want that my handy
is goes ringing all seconds I must make
it on still my empty the it's amazing
it's really amazing what's happened yeah
mashallah so you have now you mentioned
that now you have even you had a strong
mind but now you even have a stronger
faith now with Islam yes yes tell me
before we go also that we see that
people they don't understand about our
love for Jesus now as a mighty messenger
how was your how was your impression
when you learned about that to be a
Muslim you have to believe in Jesus not
like a god or a son of God but as a
Messenger of God and many of the
teachings now in Islam you know about
being a good human being worshiping only
one in one God and all these other
beautiful teachings how did they connect
with you I begin now to read the Koran
and so what I know is Jesus is
of it also yeah so but no I don't know
so much about Islamic you know about the
religion so I don't want to say you know
it's wrong so better I say yes that's
why it's a whole a whole journey of
learning now like learnings growing you
know it's amazing now just like a person
learned the martial art now you slowly
like starting from from beginning and
just learning yes so much to learn
yeah it's so much is so look I have here
uh-huh Oh for prayer masha'Allah I just
learned it it's very important for me
yes and Allah that's amazing because you
give up when you when you say Allah
Allah God Almighty is the greatest you
give up the dunya and now you focused on
your Creator it's a beautiful tell us so
how you feel when you praying when you
praying to the Creator the same way
Jesus prayed and most they all prayed
like this how you feel when you make
Salah break out for me from the day and
thanks a lot for the power who gives me
for life and for everyone and I feel
like stronger in their in their when I'm
when I prayed I feel - the power I feel
it mm-hmm how is your family and your
friends the people around you how did
they accept this decision you made oh
it's amazing
a bond friend I say him come to to the
IFTA - first time and it's also a
Austrian boy and he tell me now I have
the power
maybe to say the Shahada and I look what
see yes I want to be Muslim from many
month
my brain always go to Islamic religion
this is your friend you're talking about
your friend never he told me that yeah
but now he have the power to say yes I
want to be Muslim too and their family
it's yeah they lost me so I haven't
parents you know that dies when I was
really really young so a parents for my
for my girlfriend like my parents from
love this yet we love we love you when
you find through true little chain we
stand behind you finish yesterday we
make Easter with many of the parents
from my girlfriend you know yes how old
how is how is how is the view dear that
our Austrian people how did they do they
know much about Islam like or is it just
from the media what they hear the
media's here in Austria tells nothing
not here not in Germany nothing on
Instagram I have now 83 opponents and
2000 goes to three or four people's
write me on Instagram we love you again
in so what's happened I have I haven't
Corona beer was what's happened why you
say we love you again what's the
different now so I'm Muslim down its
problem for you why you say we love you
it became you know huh a lot of people's
went now the drains in my tomb we now
see that he goes don't say hello or
nothing they goes so it's not all
sunshine yeah yeah but that
tell me the truth I see the truth now
yes may Allah the Creator the heavens
and earth give you the Riz give you the
strength of because you have a very
powerful name now harlot even will lead
from him that you have the courage now
to continue moving forward to continue
learning to continue sharing your
message and may you affect me Allah
usually as a light to affect many people
in the positive because this is amazing
that your friend from you accepting
Islam now he's he got some courage now
to look more and to one except me
this happened with so many more people
who they see Islam is the truth because
it calls humanity to something that's in
their nature to worship one and only one
God and to do good deeds to be a good
human being this is simple to understand
and now but people are scared they
scared but when they see people like you
and others when we share their story
they get encouraged you know they start
to think and insha'Allah that much good
can come from this Allah it's bright so
a lot of people's write me on Instagram
or Facebook they write mashallah my
brother now you give up the power back
again we begin to pray yesterday oh yeah
we see you
believable for me this is unbelievable I
can't believe really I can't believe
marshal amazing thank you very much
brother it was really nice to talk with
you may Allah continue to bless you and
use you for goodness and insha'Allah
either we can maybe because we usually
take a flight there to Bosnia also it
awesome so you live in Austria huh in
Austria yes we they have the short
connection it's like one hour flight
also tebah have you ever been to Bosnia
so I have a good friend for me he's
written by Rama is my manager - so we've
he's out banging guy yeah and we fly to
Albania and yeah you know Buda becomes
from a brother for converts to Islam it
gives me that
what I can't look oh it seems man uh-huh
you know that what is it is a small
bottle of puffer always when I smell
that I know the day when I converted to
Islam
so this my brother Khalid you know and
yeah yeah it's comes from hurt and I
love this brother yeah anything you want
to say now to the world for people now
who are listening any last people who've
had a bad impression about Islam they
think Islam is about terrorism about
evil crazy things on their mind what
what do you but they're listening to you
and they've listened to some of our
shows and they see the beauty of Islam
but they're you know they're they're
listening now what would you say to them
what advice would you give whatever
whatever I say I think there's helps
nothing so a lot of um what Allah gives
only bond is did they to look and to
watch to Islam they what he want we can
say whatever we want people's always
hate and hate and hate so for people who
knows me or who looks my videos or
whatever so I hopefully a lot of
people's fun and the true religion and
find her own peace this is very
important for me peace or a lot of hate
in this world it's really amazing and so
yeah how did the make for you yes Holly
thank you very much it was nice
inshallah God willing we can we can hook
up in person maybe in Istanbul maybe in
Bosnia maybe Austria inshallah we meet
in person next time it's all lovely
woodsy may Allah bless you hippo me too
nice video as Salam alaikum peace be
with you and that was our brother will
Hamad professional fighter who now goes
by the name harlot named after holiday
bin Walid and we can take three points
from this that I was thinking
Wow it's amazing how something like the
coronavirus something that people
perceive is something very evil how many
people now like him because this
coronavirus helped as he said to
facilitate him to start to think because
now everything just calmed down life
just calm down because you isolated and
and now that he's isolated like many
people all over the world locked out and
then with the mass media and all the
fear-mongering and and the death the
reality of death is hitting a lot of
people and now everything he learned
from before that made sense about Islam
he got to as the tides calmed everything
was more just relaxed got out of the rat
race of life locked down in the house
starting to think ponder and now that
brought him to doing what is just
natural to testify that there's nothing
worthy of worship except the crater that
heavens an earth and Arabic Allah and
Aramaic in the name the language Jesus
spoke aloha that's the one and only one
creator not a human being and I was
thinking out of stone not anything in
creation day you're gonna first negate
like he did I'm not gonna worship money
fame power my ideas I'm not gonna
worship a messenger as saying nothing in
creation but the one who created me that
just makes sense and Muhammad is the
last and final messenger and then point
number two is that what is courage just
think about that how many people like
him and you have people who have gone on
to achieve great titles and ranks and
other people also in other professions
and who have strong you know resolve and
courage for material gain but what about
the courage now to go against what
people are going to say my social media
followers and family and friends peer
pressure that takes a lot of resolve and
courage that's courage to stand for
truth now he knew he didn't suppress
like many people they come to it the
truth of the pure monotheism of Islam
but they suppress it and they'll all let
it out true courage is to stand for
truth and that's what he did and point
number three what is actually Islam for
those tuning in for the first time what
is
you hear this term it's just like you're
trying to describe someone who okay
who's that person well that person one
who's dedicated his or her life to
follow the guidance that God Almighty
sent to be a good human being to be
morally upright by the time you explain
that it's a long paragraph but that is
summed up with one word that's what a
Muslim is one who submits his or her
will to the creator that happens on
earth and they're doing Islam Islam is
to achieve that peace that contentment
that happiness by submitting your will
to the will of the creator than the
heavens and of the Creator that have is
in earth that's what Islam is to be
morally upright to stand for justice to
stand for truth to be a good overall
human being it doesn't call you to be a
terrorist and do evil things no it's the
opposite and this is his story we're
sharing it with you and if you want to
accept as beautiful your life think
about it because death is a reality and
now with this whole coronavirus thing
going on hey what if you die what if I
mean even the chances are just you know
would beyond the fear-mongering
everything but still deaf can come and
for those who are just truly just scared
and scared know that Salam gives you the
good amazing feeling that at the end
this life is short and I'm gonna
inshallah have a better life in Jena but
the Hellfire is real also you can't just
charge up all these bills and at the end
you want to check out and then they
gonna bring you a bill everything you
did in this life because his life is a
test so now is the time to get it right
think ponder we weren't just created to
play and go to nightclubs and drink and
party no this is an examination and the
creator sent messengers to guide us
Jesus was one of them Abraham Moses Noah
in the last and final message of Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
he's the last to final measure he came
with the ultimate evidence approved the
Quran read it put it to the test
put your ego and your pride and all this
to the side and ask the crater alone for
guidance ask ass start to do that
homework and reflect over many of these
things that we have shared with you
continue to watch the Deen show you can
go ahead and subscribe to get our shows
sent to you weekly interact with us
support our efforts we'll see you next
time until then peace be with you I said
I want a comb
you know
[Music]